نعم بالفعل شكوى نقص الخيام لا تقارن
بالشكوى التي كنا نستمع اليها بانهم ما
زالوا هنا من اربعه ايام بانتظار خبر عن
العوائل التي ما زالت تحت ركام المنازل
سنقترب منهم اكثر
رصدنا عيونها عيون هؤلاء تترقب تنظر
باتجاه هذه المباني على امل ان يتم الحديث
او ان يكون هناك اشاره عن وجود امل لاخراج
احد الناجين او اخراج من هم قد قضوا تحت
هذا المبنى اربعه ايام وهم يجلسون في هذا
المكان
قد يكون هناك قد جهز خيام في موقع اخر
بالقرب من هنا الا انهم ما زالوا في هذا
المكان بالقرب من
المبنى المدمر عيونهم تشخص الى هذا المبنى
وكلها رجاء كلها امل ان يكون هناك نبا بين
الفينه والاخرى عن اخراج عوائل من من هناك
حاولنا
التكلم اليهم لكن الالم الكبير الذي
يعتصرهم
يعني شيء شيء لا يوصف شيء لا يوصف بكل
معنى الكلمه كل ما المشكله يعني
الذين ينتظرون
ويعملون في الحصول على ناجين
المشكله في ان يعني بعض الاماكن توقفت
فيها عمليات الانقاذ ربما نظرا لانه لا
اصوات تصدر وهذا
يزيد من الم هؤلاء
نعم بالفعل في الايام في الساعات الاولى
واليومين بعد حدوث الزلزال كانت هناك شعور
مختلف كان هناك بين الفين والاخرى تصفيق
ابتهاج باخراج ناجين لكن كلما زاد الوقت
كانت هذه الامور تتضائل فرص العثور على
ناجين تتضاءل هناك الكثير من من هم تحت
انقاذ هذه
المباني والعائلات هنا تنتظر هناك عائلات
ايضا هم من هم هم ليسوا من من هذه المدينه
بالاصل هناك من السوريين ايضا هنا
ينتظرون تحت ينتظرونا هنا ان تخرج هناك
اخبار عن عوائلهم من تحت انقاض هذا المبنى
قد نستطيع التحدث الى بعض منهم لو حدث
والله منذ اربعه ايام ونحن متواجدون هنا
في انتظار
عوائلنا الحمد لله عمي ومرت عمي قدرنا نطا
لكن ابن عمي وامراته هو ابنه لم نستطيع
الى في اخبار لا يوجد اي خبر مع الاسف
الكل بينتظروا نفس العائله ولا
نفس العائله ان شاء الله تسمعوا اخبار
طيبه
[موسيقى]
اذا
كما نتابع هي حاله ترقى حاله رجاء
على امل ان يحدث
فرح الزمان تحدثت قبل قليل الانسانيه
قبل قليل عن تركيز الجهود الان في غازي
عنتاب هل لاحظتم اي تبدل في الجهود
المبذوله اي تطور في هذه الجهود
نحن هنا منذ حدوث هذا الزلزال انا اسكن في
هذه في هذه الولايه
منذ البدايه هرعت فرق الانقاذ وكلما كانت
تتقدم يتقدم الوقت كان هناك وصول فرق
اضافيه بالاضافه الى وصول معدات جميع
الابنيه التي هنا رصدناها في عنتاب يتواجد
فيها فرق يتواجد فيها معدات لكن حجم
الدمار ضخم حجم الدمار ضخم رقعه الزلزال
واسعه يعني كل يعني في كل في كل حي هناك
دمار لكن الدمار الاكبر عندما انتقلنا الى
مدن اخرى هنا في هذه الولايه يوم امس كنت
في ولايه في مدينه نوردا هذه المدينه اجزم
ان لا يوجد هناك بناء واحد صالح للسكن ان
لم تكن ان لم يكن مدمر هو ايل للسقوط حجم
الدمار كان بها كبير جدا حجم الضحايا كبير
ورصدنا رصدنا وصول فرق اجنبيه الى الى
الموقع وكانت تساعد في عمليه رفع الانقاذ
وايضا لديها طرق مختلفه رصدناها وهي تحاول
الوصول عبر كاميرات حراريه او اجهزه اخرى
او كاميرات تعقب للوصول الى الى وجود
ناجينا في هذا الموقع ونحن في كل مكان كنا
نصل اليه نجد نفس نفس هذه المشاهد المؤثره
مباني مدمره كهذا المبنى الذي يظهر امامنا
وبجانب هذه المباني مدنيون ما زالوا
ينتظرون انباء عن عوائلهم بالانتقال الى
الوضع الانساني الوضع الانساني ما زال صعب
جدا وزير البيئه والاسكان وزير البيئه
والاسكان تحدث عن ان هناك عمليه انتشار
لما يقارب 5,000 موظف هؤلاء الخمسه الاف
موظف سيحددون ان كانت هناك ابنيه صالحه
للسكن وبعدها سيتم ابلاغ الاهالي للعوده
اليها اذا ما زلنا نتحدث عن ان الاهالي
حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد عوده الى منازلهم
وهم ما زالوا يعانون في درجات حراره
متدنيه هنا تحت هنا في هذه الولايه وايضا
في معظم الولايات التي ضربها الزلزال ما
زال هناك معاناه كبيره للاهالي جزء كبير
منهم ناموا في السيارات جزء اخر ايضا
متواجد في دور الايواء ومع حديث عن توفير
مساكن وزير البيئه والاسكان تحدث عن توفير
بيت متنقل وتحدث انه يرتفع العدد الى 15
الف بيت ايضا تحدث عن بناء 15 الف
خيمه ويتحدث عن مضاعفه لهذا الرقم فيما
بعد اذا هذه الامور مستمره لكن جميع هذه
الجهود المبذوله لا تقارن بحجم الماساه
نحن نتحدث عن امر ماساوي كل اليك ساعود
اليك ولكن هذه النقطه